wir bei verbrechen im niedersächsischen
neuenkirchen am montagabend wird die
polizei zum brand eines hauses gerufen
vor dem haus finden die beamten
plötzlich eine schwer verletzte frau im
inneren selbst dann die grausige
entdeckung dort liegen die leichen eines
mannes und einer weiteren frau nach dem
stand der jetzigen ermittlungen geht die
polizei von einem tötungsdelikt aus
zu den genauen tatumständen können
allerdings noch keine einzelheiten
genannt werden der zentrale
kriminaldienst der polizeiinspektion
soltau hat die ermittlungen aufgenommen
ein kollege jan henrik dobers steht
jetzt in neuenkirchen jan-henrik was
kannst du uns bereits über die identität
der toten sagen der unsere recherchen
haben heute ergeben dass in dem haus vor
denen wir jetzt stehen das immer noch
abgesperrt ist das lehrerehepaar wird
und andere geräte lebten die beiden
waren hier in der nachbarschaft sehr
geschäft und haben hier auch schon viele
viele jahre gelebt
hatten sich dass ein neues auto
angeschafft wollten dieser tage mit
ihrem wohnmobil in den urlaub fahren
und als dann gestern abend eine
nachbarin und freundin ihr besuch war
kam es mit diesem mordanschlag hinter
mir gibt es jetzt bereits updates neue
informationen zum entwicklung zum
entschuldigung zum ermittlungsstand bei
dieser tat also die behörden gehen ganz
klar davon aus das ist eben ein
gewaltverbrechen war also eine bluttat
hier in diesem haus hinter uns
stattgefunden hat es ist auch heute hier
im umkreis dieses hauses mit einem
spüren mit einem spürhund abgesucht
worden in einem waldstück sind viele
polizisten haben dieses durch kennt und
haben dort nach beweisstücken gesucht
welche darüber schweigt man sich hier
aus und es gab wohl heute auch einen
anfangsverdacht gegen einen
tatverdächtigen den die polizei im
visier hatte da hat uns die
staatsanwaltschaft aber am nachmittag
gesagt den musste man wieder gehen
lassen
der hatte nichts damit zu tun was lerne
ist er jus ist genau das nachbarhaus
gegenüber dort kam es vor rund sechs
wochen auch schon mal zu einem
brandanschlag wo eine eine waschmaschine
angezündet wurden im treppenhaus feuer
gelegt wurde und hier ist es wohl auch
so gewesen
ob das ein reiner brandanschlag ist
gewesen ist das weiß man nicht aber nach
dieser bluttat wurde hier auf jeden fall
feuer gewesen